ضخمه وفي النهايه نجاح المشروع لن يدر على
استراليا اكثر من 12 غواصه عدد زهيد
مقارنه بسبع وسبعين غواصه تمتلكها الصين
فما الذي يقلق بكين اذا اسطوله الغواصات
الاسترانيه قادر على تحقيق التوازن في
منطقه المحيط الهادئ وتوازن التكنولوجي
وليس كميا ميدان الصراع في المحيط الهادئ
تقدر المسافات فيه بالاف الكيلومترات
قاعده الغواصات الاستراليه في ديلايد مثلا
تبعد عن قاعده هاينان الصينيه للغواصات
باكثر من 11 الف كيلو متر مسافه تقطعها
الغواصات خلال الثلاثه اسابيع على الاقل
وهنا الفرق غواصه الديزل القادره على
البقاء تحت الماء اسبوعا واحدا فقط عكس
الغواصه النوويه التي تضطر للعوده الى
مينائها مره كل ثلاث سنوات ليس للتزود
بالوقود بل للتزود بغذاء للطاقه الغواصات
النوويه ايضا لا تخلو من العيوب المفاعل
يحتاج للتبريد باستمرار حتى في حاله
التوقف وتصريف مياه التبريد الساخنه
فالمياه الساخنه تترك بصمه تتعرف عليها
المقاتلات المضاده